really positive outcomes but there are
certainly some risks certainly we've
heard from folks like you on and Nick
Bostrom concerned about a eyes potential
to outpace our ability to understand it
what about those concerns and and how do
we think about that moving forward to
protect not only ourselves but humanity
at scale so let me start with what I
think is the more immediate concern
that's a solvable problem but we have to
be mindful of it and that is this
category of specialized AI if you've got
a computer that can play gold this is a
pretty complicated game with a lot of
variations developing an algorithm that
simply says maximize profits on the new
york stock exchange is probably within
sight and if one person or one
organization got there first they could
bring down the stock market pretty
quickly or at least they could you know
raise questions about the integrity of
the financial markets a an algorithm
that said go figure out how to launch Bo
penetrate the nuclear code in a country
and figure out how to launch some
missiles if that's their only job it's
very narrow it doesn't require a super
intelligence it just requires a really
effective algorithm then and if it's
self teaching then you know you got
problems so so part of I think my
directive to my national security team
is don't worry as much yet about
machines taking over the world
do worry about the capacity of either
non-state actors or hostile actors to
penetrate systems and in that sense it's
not
it is not conceptually different or
[Music]
different in a legal sense than a lot of
the cybersecurity work that we're doing
it just means that we're going to have
to be better because those who might
deploy these systems are going to be a
lot better now I think as a precaution
and you know all of us have spoken folks
like Elon Musk who were concerned about
the the super intelligent machine it
there's some prudence in thinking about
benchmarks that would indicate some
general intelligence developing on the
horizon and if we can see that coming
over the course of three decades five
decades you know whatever the latest
estimates are if ever because there are
also arguments that this thing's a lot
more complicated than people make it out
to be then you know future generations
or our kids or our grandkids are going
to be able to see it coming and figure
it out but but I do worry right now
about specialized AI I was on the west
coast and some kid looked like he was 25
shows me a laptop and he's this this is
sort of the or not a laptop an iPad and
says this this is the future of
radiology right and he's got an
algorithm that is teaching enough
sufficient pattern recognition that over
time it's going to be a better
identifier of disease than a radiologist
would be and if that's already happening
today on an iPad
you know embedded by some kid at MIT
then you know the vulnerability of a lot
of our systems is going to be
coming around pretty quick and we're
going to have to have some preparation
for that but joy may have worst
nightmares I generally agree I the only
caveat is I would say there are a few
people who believe that generally it
will happen at some fairly high
percentage chance in the next ten years
people who are smart so I do think that
being keeping aware but but what would
it the way I look at it is that there's
only a dozen or two different
breakthroughs that need to happen for
each of the pieces so you can kind of
monitor it's sort of and you don't know
exactly when they're going to happen
because they're by definition
breakthroughs and I think it's it's kind
of when you think these breakthroughs
will happen right and you just have to
have somebody close to the the power
cord yes right right when you said about
- Ana gotta yank that hang about
electricity
with the president that it's the short
term it's going to be bad people using a
is for bad things and there'll be an
extension of us and and then there's
this other meta thing which happens
which is a group of people so so if you
look at all of the hate on the Internet
it's not one person doesn't control that
but it's a thing it's pointed it points
at things it's definitely fueling some
political activity right now but it's
kind of got a life of its own it's not
even code it's a culture and you see
that also in the Middle East right so
why it's so hard to prevent it yet
because it actually gets stronger the
more you attack it and and to me what's
curious and interesting is going to be
the relationship between an AI say a
service that that runs like that and
then you throw in Bitcoin which is the
ability to move money around by a
machine anonymously and so so to me it
will be this weird and again this is
where I think it could be embedded if
you if you gave this sort of mob more
tools to because that they are actually
fairly coordinated in their own peculiar
way and them and so and the good side is
you can imagine you know I was talking
to some politicians like Michael Johnson
in Colorado he's trying to figure out
how can we harness these things to
inform and engage citizen
that the trick is if the problem is if
you suppress it
because of fear the bad guys will still
use it and what's important is to get
people who want to use it for good
communities and leaders and and figure
out how to get them to use it so that
they that that's where we start to lean
yeah this may not be a precise analogy
you know traditionally when we think
about security and protecting ourselves
we think in terms of we need armor or
walls from swords blunt instruments etc
and increasingly I find myself looking
to medicine and thinking about viruses
antibodies right you know how do you
create healthy systems that can ward off
destructive elements and distributed and
in a distributed way and and that
requires more imagination and we're not
very it's part of the reason why
cybersecurity continues to be so hard is
because the threat is not a bunch of
tanks rolling at you but a whole bunch
of systems that may be vulnerable to a
worm getting in there it means that
we've got to think differently about our
security make different investments that
may not be as sexy but actually may end
up being as important as anything and
the part of the reason I think about
this is because I also think that what I
spend a lot of time worrying about are
things like pandemic
you can't build walls in order to
prevent you know the next airborne
lethal flu from landing on our shores
it instead what we have to do is be able
to set up systems to you know create
public health systems in all parts of
the world
quick triggers that tell us when we see
something emerging making sure we've got
quick protocols systems that allow us to
make that vaccines a lot smarter so if
you think if you take that model a
public health model and you think about
how we can deal with the you know the
problems with cybersecurity a lot of
that may end up being really helpful in
thinking about the AI threats and and
just one thing that I think is
interesting is when we start to look at
microbiome and microbes everywhere
there's a lot of evidence to show that
introducing good bacteria to fight
against bad bacteria is a strategy and
not to sterilize and I think that well I
don't look sunny and bold like me
when I want them when I when I walk them
in the South Lawn some of the things I
see them picking up it's actually I'm a
worker in director over here and I think
that research just reading the shine
that actually opening windows in
hospitals instead of sterilizing there
may actually limit it so we have to
rethink what clean means and it's
similar whether you're talking about
cyber security or or national security I
think that the notion that you can make
strict borders or that you can eliminate
every possible pathogen is difficult and
I think I think that that in that sense
you're in your position to be able to
see medicine and and cyber and I think
that's an important reversal so there
are distributed threats but is there
also the risk that this creates a new
kind of arms race look I think there's
no doubt that developing international
norms rules protocols verification
mechanisms around cybersecurity
generally and AI in particular is in its
infancy
and part of the reason for that is as
joy identified you got a lot of
non-state actors who are the biggest
players part of the problem is is that
identifies buying who's doing what is
much more difficult yeah if you're
building a bunch of ICBMs we see them if
somebody sitting in a keyboard we don't
and so we've begun this conversation a
lot of the conversation right now is not
at the level of you know dealing with
real sophisticated AI but has more to do
with essentially States establishing
norms about how they use their cyber
capabilities part of what makes this an
interesting problem is is that the line
between offense and defense is pretty
blurred the truth of the matter is and
part of the reason why for example the
debate here about cyber security who are
you more afraid of Big Brother in the
state or the guy who's trying to empty
out your bank account part of the reason
that's so difficult is that if we're
going to police this Wild West whether
it's the Internet or AI or any of these
other areas then by definition the
government's got to have capabilities if
it's got capabilities then they're
subject to abuse and at a time when
there's been a lot of mistrust built up
about government that makes it difficult
and when you have countries around the
world who see America as the preeminent
cyber power now is the time for us to
say we're willing to restrain ourselves
if you are willing to restrain
yourselves the challenge is the most
sophisticated state actors Russia China
Iran
don't always embody the same norms or
values that we do but we're going to
have to surface this as an international
issue in order for us to be effective
because it's effectively it's a
borderless problem and ultimately all
states are going to have to worry about
this a it is very short-sighted if
there's a state that thinks that it can
develop super capacities in this area
without some twenty five-year-old kid in
a basement somewhere figuring that out
pretty quick
[Music]